hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the air things masters uh it's
yanni ponchi versus magnus carson and
this is game four uh all three games
that uh
happened right before this one were
simply a spectacular game one very very
uh
much a fighting game game too we've seen
that one incredibly fighting game game
three uh also a lot of chances missed uh
it's incredible that after such a such a
well such fun attacking chess all three
games ended in a draw yeah but it is as
it is and now this is game four uh we're
not going to mention the result but we
are going to enjoy the game so uh let's
check it out nipple with the white
pieces uh opens with e4 we have e5 by
magnus knight f3 knight to c6 and bishop
to c4 we have bishop to c5 so the joko
piano is on the board
and now not going for the evans gambit
but rather playing c3 going for the main
line of the joko piano we have knight to
f6 and d3 now
we have d6 magnus
nipple castles and now a5 by magnus this
is um
well not extremely rare but it is fairly
rare usually a6 displayed here
but this is going directly uh against
the white's plan of b for a4 and
advancing those pawns but white will
also have some very nice plans here
because uh by not playing a6 you also
don't control the b5 square and the
white will use this to his advantage so
here rookie one uh we have bishop to a7
and now comes knight to a3 now the
knight can come to b5 put pressure on
the bishop as the pawn is on a5 and not
on a6 with h6 by magnus knight to b5
attacking the bishop here and now bishop
to b8 uh
this way we will we will keep the bishop
pair uh strikes in the central with the
d4 and now magnus castles we have h3 and
now rook to e8 so simply continuing
development putting more defense here on
the center of the board we have bishop
back to d3 and now knight the e7
re-maneuvering the knight and getting
ready to kick away the white knight from
b5 so here we have c4 grabbing more
space in the center and now knight to g6
uh and here the position has been
reached before uh this year or rather
last month in the uh tata steel masters
it was uh reached in the game sergey
karyakin against uh jordan pamparest
uh bishop to e3 was played karaoke won
that game but here we have uh instead of
bishop to e3 d captures on e5 and it is
now as of move 14 that we have a
completely new game so here
you could capture with the pawn or the
knight magnus decides to capture with
the knight we have knight captures e d
captures on e5 and now uh nepo grabs
more space with c5 and this is a very
important move uh as after c6 is played
and it kind of has to be played the
knight is too strong here also you have
to free up your your dark square bishop
uh white now controls b6 and the d6 and
this can go a long way so knight back to
c3 uh we have bishop to e6 magnus
continues development bishop to e3 and
now queen to e7 so you could organize a
bit of an attack against the c5 pawn but
white simply has too many resources on
how to defend the pawn so queen e2 we
have bishop to c7 now and b3
knight to d7 okay putting some pressure
on the pawn but it's not a problem
knight to the a4 uh defending the pawn
and also gaining more control over the
b6 square we have rook e to d8 uh the
rook no longer serves uh uh uh
well a lot of purpose on e8 so magnus
shifted over to the d file and rook a to
d1 we have knight to f8 and now queen
back to c2 uh rook to d7 maybe doubling
up on the d file uh but now bishop to f1
uh here nipple offers the rook trade
before magnus doubles rooks on the d
file rook captures on d1 with rook
captures and now rook to d8 and here uh
once uh the the rooks are off the board
it should be a little bit easier to to
play this with black but nipple decides
that the rooks will remain on the board
he plays rook back to b1 and now he
might have some a3b for ideas b5 maybe
pushing some uh something on the queen
side uh so here we have knight uh back
to d7 by magnus and nepo goes uh for the
uh not even for a3 he goes straight to
b4 uh we have a captures on b4 rook
captures on b4 now attacking b7 and
magnus has to make a choice here does he
defend the pawn or does he trade the
pawn one way to do it is to play b5 but
this requires uh well
a lot of courage and a lot of uh
calculating because after c captures on
b5 uh what's defending your rook on b4
nothing really uh you have to
give it up for b captures on c7
attacking the rook on d8 and only after
rook to c8 we're gonna play queen
captures on c6 now defend our knight
here and it looks incredibly dangerous
to play this for black but once you find
rook captures on c7
you can see that now everything is
perfectly fine queen captures queen
captures and you get this position with
uh
well equal material uh only uh well not
equal material white does have the the
past a pawn uh but it should not be a
problem uh we we will capture it and
then it will be equal material there's
no way white can prevent this
uh so that's one way to do it but maybe
magnus saw it maybe he didn't want to go
for such a quick draw maybe he didn't
maybe he uh it's it's hard to say rook
the b8 was played and now nipple plays
rook to b2 puts more pressure on b7 and
only now magnus plays b5 and now the
difference is uh
you can also you can still capture on b6
alpha and it is definitely the best idea
but now
we go into the c captures on b6 and
bishop to d6 now the rook
is out of squares
and
you have to give it up yeah so here a3
uh magnus grabs the rook bishop captures
on b4 a captures and queen to d6 now
so now nipple has a very dangerous pass
pawn here on b6 that's very well
defended
but can he do something about it uh he
he definitely can however this position
has to be played out with absolute
precision uh with ideas like queen to b1
and the queen to b1 it's a hard move to
make unless you realize what black is
planning so
once we see what black is playing then
it will make more sense here nipple
played bishop to e2 and it's one of the
lesser moves you could make in this
position because it really allows white
black to grab the initiative here so
feel free to pause the video and figure
out what nipple missed in the position
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
bishop here is undefended and that yes
it's possible to take advantage of this
look at this this bishop covers a2 look
at this rook coming to a8 rook coming to
a2 rook grabbing bishop on e2 so many
moves through so many pieces but then
again it's possible uh and here after
bishop to e2 magnus very quickly played
rook to a8 and now you see the problem
with this bishop to e2 move now if you
go knight to c5 which would uh otherwise
be a a great plan now we just play rook
to a2 and we win this bishop here so
instead after rook to a8 we have bishop
to c5 the knight unfortunately has to
remain here for the moment we attack the
queen
knight captures on c5 and now how does
nipple recapture well the only way uh
well actually to capture it is by
playing b captures on c5 this comes with
tempo black has to react to this and uh
you don't have time to capture the
knight but it's still very tricky queen
d4 forcing a queen trait because the
knight is hanging and okay first we have
to also explore b7 if b7 we're just
going to play rook to b8 and now this
pawn is a weak pawn it's gonna fall so
nothing to worry about here uh but
instead uh instead of this we could
trade for example queen captures e
captures and now once we save the knight
knight to the b2 we're gonna play rook
to a2 attacking the knight if the knight
moves you lose the bishop but not really
after knights the d3 uh we can't capture
the bishop because if we capture the
bishop then we get b7 and there's no
rook b2 the knight is defending that
square so we would have to find
something else and that something else
is bishop to c8 we guard the b7 square
and now the position is much much better
for black it would still take a lot of
grinding to win this but this would be
why it's the best way to defend however
nipple said uh nope let's go for knight
captures on c5 i'm allowing you to play
uh rook to a2 and now the fun really
begins we have rook to a2 and the
situation on the clock is a nipple some
two minutes on the clock magnus six
minutes on the clock uh we have queen to
c3
rook captures on e2 and now b7 uh so how
do you uh stop the pawn okay the b8
square is defended by the queen but
let's say knight to a6 then the pawn is
coming to b8 and here magnus thought
about the position he i think it took
him some maybe even three minutes here
to figure out the best move and uh well
he didn't go for the best idea he played
queen to c7 and it seems like uh such a
such a nice idea because it defends
against most threats but
the problem is after queen to c7 okay
here knight to a6 doesn't really do
anything because we simply capture the
b7 pawn but he missed one very important
thing and that one very important thing
is queen to a3 and the thing is you have
to play queen to b8 and we're gonna
show y after queen to b8 instead of
queen to c7 uh queen to a3 is simply met
with rook to a2 that's it there's no
queen to a8 and we don't have to worry
about anything here black is just
completely winning however after the
move magnus made queen to c7 uh here
nipple played queen to a3 magnus uh now
saw that this will simply not do because
now the same idea of rook to a2 is met
with the well just a disgusting knight
captures on e6 and here you can resign
as black because it doesn't matter what
you do if you uh play well you you can't
do anything you can capture on b7 then
we capture the uh rook here and after i
have captures queen capture 76 with
check king is gonna move and then we're
gonna defend our pawn here we're up upon
in a queen's end game uh of course this
is completely winning and another thing
after knight captures on e6 you could
play rook captain uh
on a3 but after knight captures on c7
again there's no way to stop promotion
so this is what magnus missed after he
put the queen on c7 uh instead of uh on
b8 and nepo very quickly capitalized on
this he played queen a3 he had a huge
smile on his face and he could not
believe his luck and the magnus was of
course disgusted by himself so here now
there are two ways uh to defend this
rook a2 not one of them uh you you could
play rook d2 and that's what magnus
played but there's also a fine defense
with king h7 i'm going to show it
because it's very quick and i know you
guys enjoy seeing um
very strong moves so the idea is after
queen to a8 we're going to play queen to
d6 and now after white brings the queen
into the game now we have a lot of
threats uh along the the back rank so
queen to d1 check king to h2
and now of course rook captures an f2
and here it doesn't really matter what
white does even though white has two
queens let's say queen h8 check king to
g6 now let's say knight captures an e6
check you have to play something to try
and reach the black king but now we
ignore this rook captures on g2 and this
is now a draw king captures queen e2
check and as the white black queen can
use all of these squares to check the
king it's not a problem we can just
continue checking king has to go back we
need to recheck and so on uh it's a
perpetual
so that's one way to do it uh just by
playing king to h7 but i mean who plays
king h7 in a position like this with uh
well mere seconds on the clock uh so
here rook the d2 was played trying to
meet a queen to a8 with rook to d8 and
this is uh what happened in the actual
game so queen to a8 check rook to d8
blocking now comes knight to a6
guarding the the ba square and also if
rook captures we're just going to bring
another queen into the game so here
queen to d6 and now uh nipple goes for
the uh well for the main line queen
capture 78 with check queen captures and
the b8 with queen uh we have queen to c8
you do not want to go into into the end
game because then after knight captures
this will also be hanging could be a
little bit dangerous nothing serious but
if you don't have to allow it uh queen
to c8 so force white to capture so you
already have a temple on the knight so
here we have f3
uh f6 by magnus and now queen to b6 nepo
decides to keep the queens on the board
he will now try to push this for a win
uh bishop to c4 magnus wants to trade
nepal declines this knight to c5 with
king to h7
getting the king away from all the
checks and nepal does the same king h2
with h5 h4 and here we have king to g6
now both players are definitely under
one minute uh under the one minute mark
and here king g3
so how can this game continue well i
don't think either of them wanted to
play this game any any longer uh they
simply endured and suffered too much and
here they just uh well after this king
to h7 move uh went for king h2 king to
g6 uh and now okay they didn't repeat
the
position with the kings but we had a
queen a7 queen to d8 and now queen to b7
so trying a few more few more moves uh
queen to d2 was played in ipo even uh
magnus even finds a little trick here
trying to give up the c6 pawn to go
after the g2 pawn uh but just to show
you maybe why nippo decided to keep the
game alive uh for example let's say
magnus plays the knight bishop to b5 it
seems like
such a fine move you know just wasting
the move all of a sudden queen captures
on g7 check even that's in the position
king captures 96 check uh after the king
moves wherever we pick up the queen
we're up upon we're gonna win this end
game uh so that's why of course people
had to try and keep things alive but
magnus just goes queen to d2 he gives up
the c6 pawn uh to go after the g2 pawn
and that's pretty much all there is
queen captures in c6 bishop to f1 going
after the pawn queen to e8 with check
and now it's impossible to get out of
checks because f5 and the g5 are covered
so king the h6 we have queen to h8
checking the g6 queen to e8 and uh of
course you don't go to h7 because queen
captures here so king h6 queen to h8 we
have king the g6 and queen the e8 with
check and he was in this position on
move 57 that nipple and magnus agree to
a draw as there is nothing more to be
done here so really incredible that
after four games of uh such immense
fighting chess uh that the result is
four draws uh i mean if you said uh you
know to someone okay they played four
draws uh probably they would be like
yeah okay i'm not gonna watch it but
they were incredibly fighting games okay
we only cover two of them maybe tomorrow
morning i can cover game three because
that was also uh uh just a bloodbath but
we'll see how it goes uh so yeah that's
the game and the first match hope you
guys enjoyed that everything will be
decided tomorrow uh even though i still
can't believe that all four games ended
in a draw but that's that's just for you
uh and uh yeah i would like to thank uh
cypher kicks uh leo joel bourne uh james
o'toole john cousins and nikita nicholas
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the second
day of the of the finals um uh until it
ends so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day